calling a man bold counts as sexual
harassment UK judge rules argued that
the use of the word bald as an insult
related to a protected characteristic of
three members of the tribunal who
decided on the ruling and alluded to
their own experience of hair loss said
that baldness was more prevalent in men
than women the tribunal compared calling
a man bold to commenting on the size of
a woman's breasts the ruling published
Wednesday was made on a case where the
insult was alleged to have been used
against Tony Finn who was fired last
year and the circumstances around his
dismissal were also part of the case
Finn claimed that he was called a bald
the tribunal determined that using this
insult was a violation against the
claimant's dignity it was an
intimidating environment it was done for
that purpose and it related to the
claimants ladies and gentlemen do not
call a man bald or you will get serious
trouble